off the street and we need we need a
domestic terrorism law we can do without
infringing on anyone's free speech
without tampering with anybody's
liberties quite simply we have to make
the same commitment as a nation to root
out domestic terrorism we have to
stopping the international terrorism I
wish I could say that this all began
with Donald Trump it will end with him
but it didn't and I won't American
history is not a fairy tale the battle
for this soul the nation has been a
constant pushing poll for 243 years
between the American ideal that says
were all created equal and the harsh
reality that racism has long torn us
apart the same document that promised to
secure the blessings of liberty to
ourselves and our posterity also allowed
for slavery and the so called
three-fifths compromise that discount at
the very humanity of black people in
America at a time
the honest truth is both elements are
part of the American character at our
best the American ideal wins out but
it's never a rout it's always a fight
and it's a battle that is never fully
finished go back to the beginning Thomas
Jefferson wrote what many believed to be
the most important document civil
document in human history and he was a
slaveholder we've never lived up to our
American ideals Jefferson himself didn't
but what he wrote has pulled us towards
justice for
more than two centuries and it still
does remains this nation's North Star
take a look at the Klan Ku Klux Klan
after the Civil War we saw a rise in the
Klan it was beaten down only to rise up
again in the 20s in fact in august of
nineteen twenty five thirty thousand
fully clad Klansmen and their robes and
pointed hats marched down Pennsylvania
Avenue the streets of Washington imagine
imagine that today and then the Klan was
once again beaten back as it was after
the Civil War how the courts the press
and yes presidents stood against them
and that is the point our institutions
often imperfectly stood against hate at
moments when we were most tested
American presidents have stepped up in
the past George HW Bush renouncing his
membership in the NRA President Clinton
after Oklahoma City George W Bush going
to a mosque after 9/11 President Obama
after Charleston presidents who led who
oppose chose to fight for what the best
of American character is about there's
deafening silence now sadly we don't
have that today our president has
aligned himself with the darkest forces
in this nation and it makes winning this
battle for the soul of our nation that
much tougher harder Trump doesn't
understand what Franklin D Roosevelt did
Roosevelt said the presidency is quote
pre-eminently a place of
moral leadership he doesn't see what JFK
did when he said only the president
represents the national interest he's
blind to what Lyndon Baines Johnson said
of the office when he said quote nothing
makes a man come to grips more directly
with his conscience than the presidency
Trump offers no moral leadership seems
to have no interest in unifying this
nation no evidence that the presidency
has awakened his conscience in the least
indeed we have a president with a toxic
tongue who was publicly and
unapologetically embraced the political
strategy of hate racism and division so
it's up to us as it was in the 20s it's
up to us we're living through a rare
moment in this nation in history where
our president isn't up to the moment
where our president lacks the moral
authority to lead where our president
has more in common with George Wallace
than he does with George Washington you
know
we are almost 330 million Americans will
have to do what our president can't
stand together stand against hate stand
up for what the best our nation's best
when were the best in this nation we
believe when we're at our best we
believe in honesty decency treating
everyone with respect giving everyone a
fair shot leaving nobody behind giving
hate no safe harbor demonizing no one
not the poor the powerless the immigrant
or the other leading by the power of our
example not by the example of our power
that's allowed to sustain as a beacon to
the world being part of something bigger
than ourselves it's a code it's a
uniquely American code it's who we are
but Donald Trump doesn't get it but this
president doesn't understand is that
like every other nation on earth
we're unable to define what constitutes
American by religion by ethnicity or by
tribe you can't do it
America's an idea an idea is stronger
than any army bigger than any ocean more
powerful than any dictator or tyrant it
gives hope to the most desperate people
on earth and it's not only our values
that are under assault our democracies
as well a free press an independent
judiciary a legislature there is a
co-equal branch of government these are
the guardrail
[Applause]
these are the guardrails of our
democracy they're written into our
Constitution and if you've noticed for
the last two plus years they've been
under attack phrases like fake news
enemy of the people they're no joke
they're insidious they're corrosive just
look around the world the worst despot
Tsar now using chumps language to
justify their own abuses of power Trump
is China weaken our institutions the
press the courts to Congress precisely
because they are the only checks on his
power that's what this is all about the
abuse of power if there's one thing I
can't stand and I know you can't is the
abuse of power whether it's a boss
taking advantage of his or her workers
or a man who raised his hand to a woman
or a child or a president who's running
roughshod over everything this country
believes in stands
[Applause]
not how old are young you are you've
never seen anything like this in your
lifetime
we're being reminded every day if
there's nothing guaranteed about
democracy not even here in America we
have to constantly earn it we have to
protect it we have to fight for it
I believe America's and as Lincoln named
us the last best hope on earth we have
to remember why it's not because we're
the biggest economy the strongest
military in the history of the role it's
not because we have the most innovative
entrepreneurs and the greatest research
universities that's all true but it's
not why we're America the reason is what
we believe the most powerful idea in the
history of the world
I think beats in the heart of the people
of this country it beats in all of us
no matter your race your ethnicity
no matter your gender identity or sexual
orientation
no matter your faith it beats in the
hearts of the rich and poor alike a
unites America where their ancestors
were native to these shores there are
brought here forcibly and enslaved or
there are immigrants and generations
back like my family from Ireland or
those coming today looking to build a
better life for their families the
American creed that we're all created
equal
was written long ago but the genius of
every generation americans has opened it
wider and wider and wider to include
those who have been excluded in the
previous generation that's why it's
never gathered any dust in our history
books it's still alive today more than
two hundred years after its inception
but i honest to god don't believe donald
trump's sees it that way
On January 20th 2017 in his inaugural
address Donald Trump painted a dark
bleak picture of our country in crisis
we declare tonight quote this American
carnage stops right here it stops right
now but as a sitting president Trump's
anger hate and divisiveness pitting
Americans against one another train on
our divisions and doing nothing nothing
about the endemic and the epidemic of
guns is fueling a literal carnage in
America we now have more mass shootings
in the year 2019 since January then we
have days the past since January 1 2019
as of Monday according to the data from
the gun violence archives there have
been 255 mass shootings
in the first 217 days of this year you
can't listen to us go on we can't and I
will not let this man be reelected
president of the United States of
America
[Applause]
[Applause]
his incompetence his immorality his
carnage stops with us right here right
now starting in the Midwest limited to
four years I believe and I really do
believe this that history will look back
on this president as an aberrant moment
in American history but if Donald Trump
is reelected I believe he will forever
and fundamentally alter the character of
this nation if we give Donald Trump four
more years this will not be the country
envisioned by Washington and Adams and
Jefferson we give Donald Trump four more
years
this will not be the nation bound
together by Lincoln if we give Donald
Trump four more years this will not be
the nation lifted up by Roosevelt or
inspired by Kennedy will not be the
nation that Barack Obama proved tour
bends toward justice
the danger
[Applause]
the danger Donald Trump and the
alt-right posed to this nation isn't
hypothetical or exaggerated it's real
the core values is this nation our
standing in the world our very democracy
everything that makes America America is
at stake folks
everyone knows who Donald Trump is even
the people who support him we have to
show who we are we choose hope over fear
we choose science over fiction we choose
unity over division and yes we choose
truth over lies
[Applause]
if we stand together if we stand
together we will win the battle for the
soul of this nation where the United
States America there's not a single
thing beyond our capacity if we stand
together and get up and remember who we
are this is the United States of America
period thank you and may God protect our
troops
[Applause]